a europe that protects the climate was our
motto at the start of the council
presidency the hydrogen
declaration at the informal council in
linz was a milestone on our part we
want to put green technologies in the
fast lane, not only in
transport but above all in
the industrial sector we have that in
europe  the first hydrogen declaration was signed
together with almost all member
states this week was really
the week of climate protection in europe for
us we achieved the co2 reductions in cars
and vans that was a
milestone
we finished negotiating the reduction of single-use
plastic around our
nature also to be kept clean and
last but not least we have concluded the
cleanenergy package the
largest legislative package in the
history of eu energy policy with the
kind lg package we are
primarily concerned with strengthening the
consumer role
we put the consumer in the
to become the center  n termination
fees for households and for
small businesses are
generally prohibited when
changing providers. consumers will be able to change providers within 24 hours from 20 26
every european will
benefit from this package, which will soon become
standard everywhere. computer wanted
a russian and western  direct
suffrage is already are you are it will be
necessary or by june you
reached the mark
na that will be the ddp thing from the numbers